هذا الصندوق فوقي به تلفاز قابل للدحرجة
بداخله ، فأنا أجلس
تحته حتى تتمكن من رؤية أنه
لا يتجه لأعلى ولأسفل فحسب ، بل إنه في الواقع
ينفتح خارج الصندوق ، وسنعرض
لك التكنولوجيا في ثانية ولكن في
الماضي  بضع سنوات اعتقد الكثير من الناس
أنهم يعرفون إلى أين يتجه
التلفزيون إلى أجهزة التلفزيون ثلاثية الأبعاد ، عندما كانت آخر مرة رأيت فيها
شخصًا يرتدي نظارات ثلاثية الأبعاد
تلفزيونات منحنية ولكن يحتاج إلى هؤلاء عندما
يمكنك فقط لف جهاز تلفزيون في
صندوق وتخزينه بعيدًا  منذ سنوات
هنا في CES ، عرضت لنا LG Display
نموذجًا أوليًا آخر لشاشة أصغر مقاس 18 بوصة ، لذا
قد تكون قادرًا على لفها وتثبيتها
في جيبك الخلفي كصحيفة ذات
يوم أخذوا نفس
التقنية وطبقوها على جهاز تلفزيون ولكن هذا  هو مجرد
نموذج أولي وتقوم LG Display بتصنيع
الشاشات التي يأملون في أن تدمج الشركات المصنعة للتلفاز يومًا ما
هذه التقنية في مجموعاتها ، لكن ما
يمكنك رؤيته هنا هو كيف
تعمل التكنولوجيا تحت الغطاء بينما يتقلص التلفزيون ،
فما هو  إنه يشير إلى وجود
تلفاز قابل للتلف ، يمكنك إزالته بعيدًا
عندما لا تستخدمه ولكن LG Display
تعتقد أنك قد ترغب بالفعل في استخدام
تلفازك على ارتفاعات مختلفة
ربما لمجرد معرفة الموسيقى التي يتم تشغيلها
في المنزل أو ما هو الطقس  لكنهم
يعتقدون أيضًا أنك قد ترغب في استخدام
تنسيق عريض للغاية مثلما اعتدنا في
دور السينما أو ربما مجرد
مشاهدته لمشاهدة التلفزيون بالتنسيق
الذي اعتدنا جميعًا على تخيله